reino unido es uno de los principales
socios comerciales de alemania y en
particular un destino muy importante
para las exportaciones de este país de
hecho según un estudio publicado el año
pasado unos 750 mil empleos aquí en
alemania dependen de las exportaciones
al reino unido- y las empresas alemanas
tienen unas 2500 sucursales en reino
unido- y de ahí que el acuerdo logrado
entre la unión europea y reino unido-
haya sido recibido por líderes
empresariales aquí en alemania con
cierto alivio mejor un acuerdo que
ningún acuerdo puede resumirse las
diferentes opiniones sobre ese acuerdo
logrado lo que explica también el miedo
que tenían muchos en el sector a un
posible cambio de año o caótico oa
incertidumbre también a largo plazo a
pesar del acuerdo también se nota cierta
preocupación en el sector no solamente
por la burocracia añadida a corto plazo
por los nuevos formalismos por esa etapa
de reacomodo para muchas empresas
sino también por lo que describió la
cámara de comercio británico alemana que
aseguró que la economía en este país
debe prepararse para cambios profundos a
pesar del acuerdo logrado